I'm excited to show you the original
version of gays in the Sun it starts
with the princes mother played by
Harriet Jones singing her favorite
lullaby to her son who lies in the sick
bed later it's the mother who's in bed
she's just died and the young prince is
pulled away by his father we reshot this
you know because of a mistake I made
when we previewed the movie there were
people in the audience who got confused
they thought Harry it was actually heavy
more ahem who plays Agatha the
enchantress the actresses actually
looked very much alike so sadly when we
did it again even though it is once
again Harriet we had to put her in bed
and with dark hair sadly it meant we had
to recast the boy because in the new
version it was now a singing part and we
needed someone with the trained voice
I'm thrilled to be able to finally share
what I think was a wonderful really
lovely performance from Harry Jones in
this clip
[Music]
rest now
[Music]
when we move until my own life
[Music]